this video is sponsored by raycon in
recent times the act of watching hentai
has become less of a shared secret we
all agreed to not publicly talk about to
something more akin to a celebrated meme
i watch entire you watch hentai the
sauce give me the sauce
mom did you get those yu-gi-oh cards i
asked for it said
anime so i bought it for you and you
know what i'm all for it because why
should you feel ashamed whether you're
browsing the latest dojinshi
appreciating the new pink pineapple
masterpiece or if you're feeling a bit
nostalgic and you put on a golden oldie
like bible black and treat yourself to a
good old-fashioned
legacy fat even anime has jumped on the
train with the recent abundance of shows
seemingly with hentai plots
from escorts in another world drop the
mister and get with your sister or most
recently
peter grill and the post nut clarity
it's like the entire entry has just
collectively agreed to be horny on main
but in between all the memes there's a
world i've discovered that's completely
changed my view on the medium that
showed me that plot can
sometimes be more important than plot
and even some of the most perverted
kinky degenerate content out there can
bloom into something beautiful and
touching that could even make you cry
at both ends and the series that opened
the door to that world for me was
nozokiana is a 13 volume manga series
that has been adapted into a three
episode ova that i discovered
after watching domestic girlfriend jesus
christ
what does everything in my life seem to
loop back to this [__] series because
that series sent me down this rabbit
hole to find more shows that can give me
a taste of that spice that i discovered
which
of course led me to this because if
domestic girlfriend was the ghost pepper
that almost killed me i was ready to
start munching down on a fat carolina
reaper
kilo some beta ass art school student
who moves into a new apartment
in the big city with dreams of starting
his perfect college life
girls drinking and of course an
education oh wow here you got a phd
yeah that's right i got a phd pretty
huge
dude only that was a [__] lie the
moment he steps foot in his new
apartment he finds a crack in the wall
and after peeping through it it's met
with the knife of his neighbor blasting
her gash with another vigor to overload
the pornhub servers
being caught in the act he goes over to
apologize only to trip over and face
planting the chest so hard her nipples
could have probably knocked out from
wisdom teeth but it turns out that the
female in question actually set this all
up
being the true masturbator that she is
and uses this fact to blackmail our main
man to set up some kind of messed up
system where they each take turns
spaffing went out for the other to watch
on alternating days of the week yes they
actually made a calendar schedule they
stick to like clockwork to spy on one
another this girl's coordination when it
comes to beeping is somehow more
organized than my [__] life did i
mention ozakiana literally means a
peephole what follows is a hot steamy
mess of a voyeuristic fantasy
as keto's entire college life has become
a real life only fans account where his
next door neighbor is the only
subscriber
if this sounds like a cheap premise for
a hentai plot well
did you miss the [__] title of this
video while i can be argued whether
nozakian even counts as a hentai because
like something like interspecies
reviewers the sex scenes don't
explicitly show
all the genitals it totally is for me
hell
some of the stuff here feels more
explicit than most of the real
hentai out there no expense is spared
and the smallest sadistic detail it is
hot
it is steamy there's some real kinky
[__] in here that'll make you go
[Music]
sexy anyone coming here looking for that
kind of a good time will surely be
satisfied but that's not to say that
this manga is all about its explicit
scenes
what makes a series like this stand out
from a typical hentai plot is that the
sex scenes don't just serve a single
purpose
as perverted as it can be the series
never prioritizes degenerate content in
favor of advancing the plot
in fact they are both tied together the
plot complements the hentai scenes and
the hentai scenes helped to build on the
plot
this messed up premise this truly messed
up relationship that's begun between the
main character and the people go emeru
contributes to the drama that occurs
throughout the rest of the story
kido has to continue to live out the
college campus lives in many of the
usual ways you'd expect from a team
rom-com kiro finds other love interests
he has relationships with people
falls in love and does everything else a
normal young adult would do but no
matter how much he hopes for a private
or even normal love life it's damn near
impossible when there's emery on the
other side of the wall fanning the fur
at her own pleasure whilst watching him
all while having to keep the secret of
the [__] up relationship he shares
with the person on the other side of
that
wall it quickly changes from a kinky
hentai plot to a genuinely messed up
situation but unlike a normal hentai it
never forgets the reality of it all
it knows how messed up it is and it uses
this to build up the tension and drama
surrounding the whole situation
every new chapter no matter how kinky or
perverted advances the plot or explores
a new facet of a character and through
all this adultery drama and spice you
begin to lose track of why you started
reading it in the first place you're
genuinely more interested in what's
going to happen next than what you're
holding in your dominant hand and the
reason i think it works is that behind
his perverted fantasy and passion for
degeneracy
at its core it is a romance drama and
what really sells the series is our
queen of perversion
emeru to put it quite bluntly keto is
pretty much just a generic
boring harem protagonist he's
wishy-washy wimpy and has an immature
attitude to everything
not committing to any ideals just taking
things as they come and commonly making
really bad decisions in the face of
adversity
but paired with a perverted maniac he'll
do anything she can to see him firing
off some knuckle children it results in
an interesting dynamic and some really
spicy drama
the first half of the series sees kido
forcibly put in some of the most
perverted situations you could think of
which as odd as they are also kinda make
you feel bad for him
this is a man who's in some messed up
[__] because one sex crazed psychopath
won't allow him to stop
you start to get invested in these
relationships with other girls you start
hoping you can find some modicum of the
normal love life but in the back of your
mind you start wondering
what the [__] is the deal with this girl
how can anyone be as passionate as
something in life as she is about
peeping on other people it's the mystery
of emery that makes so much of it
compelling
at the start you're led to believe that
she really is just some kind of weird
nymphomaniac
obsessed with dialling her rotary phone
in front of this crack in the wall but
somehow as more of a pass is revealed as
absurd as it sounds
her actions begin to make sense in its
own twisted logic
needless to say i really was fully
unprepared for how things would start to
unravel
look i'm not gonna sit here and tell you
that this was the most fascinating piece
of fiction i've ever read i was
interested in what was going to happen
next but let's be honest
it still felt like i was consuming some
top tier junk food with a damn near
spicy sex scene every chapter
i knew i was enjoying this series and
the fact that i cared about the plot was
just a nice little sprinkle
on top but then throughout the mid to
late stages of the story something
unthinkable happened to me i got
emotionally invested the story just
starts to dig its claws into you it's a
horny dramatic mess of a [__] up
romance that turns into a bittersweet
tale of abuse
loss and longing you start off by
cheering for kido to do everything in
his power to get rid of emiroo but the
further you read on the more you feel
like he needs her
and she definitely needs him she's a
twisted
messed up broken individual and she
knows it she's well aware of all the
[__] up way it manifests but the more
you find out about her the more you just
hope that she can find someone that
could help her through all these issues
break down all the barriers she's put up
and just find some happiness in her life
despite how much sex and kinky [__] that
was happening the
series was blueballing my heart and
because how utterly blindsided i was
that i was this invested in a story like
this
it somehow broke me down i shed a tear
i actually cried over a [__] hentai
one of the most horny kinky and
perverted series i had read
somehow hit the g-spot of my soul and it
really opened the door for me to
something new
i'm equally proud and ashamed to say
that nozoki ana awoke something in me
and no it wasn't a brand spanking new
tag for me to look out for and browsing
you hentai
i mean it wasn't only that what
nozokiana showed me was that hentai
could be more than just cheap fat
material this is an art form that can
deliver stories that can hit in a real
depth on an emotional
mental spiritual and of course erotic
level
and a story like this is truly unique
than just finding other stories that
just hit these points individually it's
a combination that you rarely ever get
to see but whenever you do discover
something like this
it's a beautiful experience that you
can't get by just watching your typical
romance anime or jacking off to your
typical hentai and this series damn well
woke my desire to find other stories
like
it while also ruining how i view hentai
forever because who the [__] is browsing
x videos and thinking to themselves you
know this porno is missing
character development your brother's
doing unspeakable things to me
what the [__] you didn't get my cereal
is this the masterpiece of a story that
will stand up with the greatest manga of
all time
no it's an erotic fantasy about some
chick buttering her crumpet while some
dude watches
but it is a rare enigma that is able to
combine this perverted premise into a
final product that's hotter than most
hentai
and more touching than most romance
manga and if you didn't know that the
world of hentai could be more than just
a service to a quick jackoff session
then
ozokiane is one of the best gateways you
can find to get into that world
there is so much more to hentai than
just wearing an ahegao hoodie passing
over some five-digit new codes and
getting a limp dick the moment you see
queen b
is adapting your favorite dojinshi and
that is why no matter what your
preference
no matter what your kinks or fantasies
the most superior hentai tag
will and always has been
plot now go crazy you [__]
degenerates just don't forget that
you'll probably need twice the amount of
tissues for this one
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
again i just want to thank raikon for
sponsoring me today look i'm just a guy
who wants to listen to his anime
openings in peace without having to
explain why i'm still
listening to the domestic girlfriend
opening again for the millionth time
because it's a [__] banger alright
just leave me alone and the reikon
earbuds allow me to do this perfectly
they're compact they're convenient
they're easy to use
all i have to do is just open them up it
connects automatically and i put them in
and just play my music they're super
comfortable so i hardly even notice it
when they're in and the case comes with
enough charge that i rarely need to
recharge it i got these about a month
ago and i use them pretty much
every day now whether i'm just going out
working out at the gym or just chilling
and it's great value for money as well
because it's about half the price of
other premium wireless earbuds while
sounding just as good
the one i got is the everyday e25 model
which is one of their best models yet
with six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and a
compact design that really gives you a
noise isolating fit and if you want
different colors they offer a wide
variety of colors and patterns
so if you want a pair today you can
click the link in the description or go
to biorecon.com for 15 percent off your
order
and also thank you to joe augustine mike
elfin
sisters10086 zob mondo lfor
basil and everyone else on my patreon
for helping to support me for this month
that's it for me today no further
updates i've been gig uk and i'll see
you all
next time